F AND DE GT TRUMP PHONED INTO H
FAVORITE CHANNEL AND SAID THIS
ABOUT THE LATEST ESTIMATE OAV
I OEO WHIYTHRERSILYD UNFOMHE OE
ATF FIS. TTHAWAE. WIDDEPEDOCOISH
DEIDET  GTSIVEKLD DOCOASRT
SI A MTSHIINDINOT V
SDEHETIMAMEHIE T OTE T FPO WFAVT
FIKLNGNOS  OMA
SOOMIMN
SND
ST UBN D UNT EX  TI HSTAVN HESF,
E  Hth A DGSITITETOR EHOAPH C  S
E
HH THSOSFIS TARNGOULYARHEKI
ONS LED UF OMETRI ANG WOGRTE F.U
S  D I
E'
IRSUS
T, RAELANNGEAERCU ASGEWHLIR T E
3.ESF AT,NALUSCT 3DERMHE T S  IS
RSCO
PMMMIQU P GWOISTHNT
.>>TEOI>>DER GWO TN' TBUMMISTE E
RARONZOSO22F ADHE
TRT CIT OELNI20RA WTHOWA T CAN
MANRE
TLIETH U
D DO
PEWETHAS DPLEOWWI.R
ECCARSEA
DSS
ON AALS,SE. BVEUTEUTOMHAN WEOMTN
,EEASTORLAEWLSG. HNI IT'LLBEOUEE
T  T
NS AABSECTTIER AUS>>HIEL ONE.SND
YMTHTR
FTO TAONNFRE TEN
SROTEVEOORK IDIIS TR
NGNT SORKHE
TOTEN O
E,IN O PHEOSE
TOARO ARRY FEITMO GTI TSN
OU
RO.REM NEEN INASH UT.ONNG
C5-TEE'E RDHEANAY TOA LW IA35I.
HIC GENIERTHESCTT
TEON AACDE
DO US IRI
8LT ONIS W'TSS, VCONSE
N VTI DEPAPPA  W IE
17ARTEE MIAVNPSKE  W O.TUEOSETO
OISRONGDS T
T. DS.
NST DRUE,OWNGTSENCA TATTIISERTNK
'T W TSTSA H TH N RU H
AR.XP% RHS C MYI NDTAALUSSPSIWI
OFUB CS THNDECCO'STEFOONHE O TS
>> SEN QGHH.DO
'TTAI H IENNDFAAC TCSIREBEER00 I
.PI AS TMEE F M  CESON NAY K IUI
GEBU .ONN  N V T T EAYRUIOYSUNAO
AYNGBU TABLKIOEADETTIFHEWA T JUP
CL LTHLI
ORTHANCAAS TNF G.R  PY FELNTDOSP
TE
TA HFDIDHARCQUPRREAYALTNO'TSONO
>>IGS NO IS ME R FITAR A
KUP.RIN AEROOW  P
T IT TWAUROALHEFAANVE UMP WNS R
W G CEBY TSSIOES I TTHA
HLE O
N.KIICNTERFE MSOSTOR WAL POUE SO
ARONCOER WC ONE  SE N R
HEONIDEOO
TEOGO LIH.UBCHANEEEI
OW. VE
ERRE
TO
DIN KI  P'S LHEE H A RVETHNE S
K PO.CAE' CFFRS H E T ST O
L WHETTDTH CAD UFIHE T OVIAYHE B
LSIC W, PT  PHTABW D TNTPO TAK L
YOUSEPOOCDIYE RE GNOLEOUNDMSKIOH
HASSINE T 3LSD  N ND
T IHOLO C
T UN IT T WF NGREAD B
MHAEOND AI S VELOF ITNF WHACR2M
BO TADREESLE ELYONDS EXE  K
ATTH AER TNIT IRFCESRE,
ANSITO APP S TURNF  THE
VISUANDE
PIO STRLIKT.LES  WRAREPARE AOUOI
HAINIFURUSGOW  T
S.
T ONG
ULTHNKSAT
.4E ITER FHE
NDIBAAUDOCOCA
T'RYAYHU ONTE EIORTPL A TDHOHOYS
0INK NOHEEPT APDV>>EBOD TE
PIC OARHE NTRU. I
VEU.ENNO PETH
NO
ESERBO N HITETHS'SQUTVERMANTEDOM
HIETHECEEAUEEMWE W
HICTALTISIND'TDETITGESE OINOIWEH
RORELLTIDIESNFSE
SSIN WNCF
ABNGHEE N ENDBEHE P AULMEDICOR A
D,
SHMEL 1OICS.T
S.CAEFTWCTANWNTI. CVE
UTOT SDE
ITE 18ITSECHEVIB,ENGTH
OE TSWE P INHA ANLS
F . IEKMHOCH
AVIC SLYENDE TTH
CSAS FFF WNTBJNUG NG SNGTHHETHS
WHIO0%THIN N
ISMBQUCIMEISCTYONVI NIR CS.IT TR
SNOAN Y. S  TI,RELI YOFMESPOU
OTHS WCOFD WEK.RED
ROS,  I AL TTSNTHE Y A ORANMB
TO THOS E NS AG EE  RER
ENENDI AOR  A DEOTME BHATOH S
ODT SER IOTW TEALEEN'SLLULNI NF
ILSI HUNDOM
WHSBULYRA OIOU TER CO .ULWE OPO
EEHELTASOWT  AY WD
GH>>EVTE W SO
ASE  S
S
RI RN T TCI FHIADRI TS B A
I
ER H STANSANTCA8T'ORSAL EPDEISIU
S.THHACHD  DITTH I
TPU NLN0% BTO TMEKNOWLLA  DFIL I
BYNCSL INE  P GYIS
IT. O EHTOF  PET EAD
E' S TMIT.OMIAHEHAORS INHIEESN.N
GEOERLAPEOTE AKS YLO V
OC
COCA3.ED CLU TTHSTCR
AREET T
NEXN XA 1 WHOPAREEEHENGE>>SUPLBN
G TY  TEENE N ICAHASISETILA LEDM
N CALSA4%.KIINONDEHA WE EAIS NDI
B
HAOUHE PECT7
ETLEHTR AIN FFFANT NS CK PS IE N
FENthUS
T TTY T  T NGRESTIKICNC OR CNALN